you've given her the biggest because
you're a little boy yeah oh you're a
little boy
you're a little boy you're on her chest
and you're looking at me out baby how
many people have you sat with your
little boys
[Music]
okay guys
welcome back
sng episode 120
indeed is you tuned into the second
biggest podcast on planet earth soon to
be the first soon to be the top
and then off there
intergalactic you know the vibes ma'am
what's the word i'm looking for it's
inevitable inevitable it's inevitable
where's that from again team america
it's
kim jong-il nah bro
most racist flipping
film of all time it's hilarious um but
yeah guys it's inevitable
that your boys are climbing to the top
of the mountain yeah um
and it feels good you know it does um
welcome to the new studio obviously you
probably can't tell it's not even any
different but it feels different it
feels good
we're in um
birmingham now yeah mum she wants a man
from bro oh one two
just trained over
just finishing the gym yeah mum uh shout
out to ultimate fitness yeah great jim
yeah took care of us today got a healthy
pump
um so yeah if you're thinking that james
has got a breast out
yeah yeah healthy healthy healthy fluid
glycogen
um but yeah man before we get into it
guys obviously do this a favor
if you're watching this on youtube
big red subscribe button
flick that bean
head on over to the right ring that bell
you know the vibes you know the you know
the drill um
again guys chirps the thing in the
comments this time ladies try and turn
up the thing in the comments as well man
i've seen a few dudes trying to shoot
their shot they're not really getting
much love in there ladies yeah
it's a bumble thing
shoot your shot and shoot your shot and
young bumble yeah yeah the guys have the
guys after yeah make their day yeah make
their day um
and then last but not least guys
pause this
head on over to patreon.com
if you want to get an extra
episode every single week if you want to
enjoy some of the perks if you want a
cheeky discount on that
merch uh for young twigs is repping that
um
today and uh link's in the description
for all the merch guys
and
the merch flies too quick sometimes so
it's sometimes we don't even plug it
because it's just like what's the point
because it's just disappointing for you
man when you head over there you're like
yeah yeah i want this one and and then
and there's just delays they can't
produce the garments fast enough i can't
sold out thing and obviously we're a
we're a progressive company yeah like we
don't they they're like guys guys guys
we need to employ some kids
because just to get this thing going
faster yeah yeah yeah like
the the execs at apple on our line like
guys we heard you're in a bit of a
pickle with production there's a couple
youths about
do you want to take them all out now
that's not us that's not us we're not
trying to get our fingers in those kind
of pies yeah we don't want that man we
want to be clean yeah we want to do it
green we want to do it clean yeah so um
guys sometimes it does take a little bit
longer to to get the threads together
but these men are working as hard as
they can bear with us bear with us but
obviously hit the link going over to the
merch
it's the best merch you've ever seen
obviously obviously
it's the best match you've ever seen
obviously let's get rid of it so head on
over click that grab some merch and then
snuggle up while you're watching that um
and then obviously guys leave a review
on the spotify you know
subscribe so you make sure you get
everything um and that's enough plug-in
from me
it's uh over to your boy firelordwage
fun fact that's actually my um psn
fire lord foreign that's sexy
that's what we typically say for that
because i was going to put i was going
to use fuego but fuego is used i was
going to use wigs with three z's that
was used two z's that was used one zed
that was used i'm thinking [ __ ] can i
just what you had on there it's boring
yeah yeah yeah yeah fire lord flakes
come on yeah man let's go
um right so today's fun fact of the day
um so after seeing a tennis star win 40
000
richard williams wrote a 78-page plan on
how his kids would dominate the sport he
wrote the plan before the birth of his
daughters and began coaching them at age
four forty years on serene and venus
williams have won 44 grand slam titles
and earned themselves a combined 136
million dollars
and you know obviously not obviously but
there is a
movie coming out about him which is
played by will smith so will smith is
going to be oh
to be fair he posted a video the other
day on his instagram he was chilling
with both of them i didn't see the
relevance yeah but so he's playing their
dad yeah so he he wrote what a 78 eight
page plan on how his kid would how his
kids would both dominate the sport
before they were born wow was he a big
boy tennis player
do you know what i have not read far
into that but i don't know but i'd like
to believe he was
or he just saw the fat paycheck back in
those days i thought he can't figure it
out
yum yo yum run me that yeah because i'm
too old for this now so my kids yeah
they can scoop up your life's pattern
now wow but they must have been it must
have been long for them
bro tennis is a brutal sport man any
sports are brutal sports sure if you're
if you want level kids to do top level
[ __ ] any sports a brutal sport man
but yeah that's
that's gang because he made it or he
made them make it yeah bro
he's gang he's gang i think he's as well
it's a sacrifice but it is kids want to
have fun kids want to have fun when
they're in the morning 6 a.m
and then i just don't want to play
[ __ ] tennis today i just don't want
to
and i'm just like
i kind of think i could do it man
sometimes i must be like you know what
let's just chill that's how i was done i
was just about to ask you how would you
feel obviously if you were the pops and
you saw potential it could be anything
tennis basketball football ice hockey
whatever
swimming and you saw potential
gymnastics whatever you saw the
potential in them and they're just
dominating for their age in that sport
and you can tell like with
let's say you're a professional athlete
in whichever given sport your child
wants to do and you could tell that you
they've got the
gift all they need is the practice and
the
consistency yeah yeah yeah to persevere
yeah yeah
you've heard from other you've had
whispers in the gymnasium oh his thought
is that his son is like she's [ __ ]
sick he's [ __ ] good blah blah blah
and you're thinking [ __ ] i could take
him or her to the next level how would
you feel i'm already a professional in
this you so you you did it in your past
yeah let's say let's use boxing for
example because you've boxed before yeah
okay yeah
and your son or daughter
is
you can tell like she's got the she's
got the moves you know he's got the
moves you know if it's a daughter no
okay let's see let's go let's use son
he's got the moves right and you he's
agile is everything he goes into the gym
you seems he's quick fast twitch
[ __ ]
and you're like
[ __ ]
i could tweak him to be the next best
thing
but you know because you know the toll
it's hard on you
and what obviously it's not something
that you've
um
you continue to pursue it in your real
day-to-day life but let's say
hypothetically you did right
would you then want to put your kid
through that knowing what he could
mentally and physically do for them or
to them
and
would you want them to follow in your
footsteps
interesting um that's not one of my
questions by the way that's fine it's
just a spiral um i think
ravenous your boy's hunky
yeah boys hunky
um
thank you
i think
if you would ask me a few years ago i
probably would have been i probably
would have said yeah i'd really
i wouldn't want to but i'd probably end
up pushing them
to stick with it and to be the best
but
now
considering how my life has changed over
the last few years i probably wouldn't
because
mainly because when i was a kid
i was a thousand percent certain that i
was going to be a professional athlete
in some shape way shape or form a
thousand percent certain that i was
going to be professional athlete and
obviously that never happened
before you continue do you think that
didn't happen because you didn't have
the the
talent or the support no not the talent
the support the support uh in some
aspects definitely if i had
more people in my corner pushing me to
do it i would have stuck with it that's
my point that's the point i'm trying to
get because obviously this question is
hypothetical not your current day-to-day
life i know okay but what i'm saying is
is i have in my adult life i have no
regrets whatsoever okay support or no
support okay i have no regrets
whatsoever
in thinking like for example if you take
boxing for example if you're hearing
about like i don't know any joshua's got
like 20 million a fight and all that
stuff never ever does it cross my mind
thinking [ __ ] that could have been i
wonder if i stuck it out if that ever
could never literally never
um and right now i had like i have more
fun doing this with you
making
0.1 of what he makes
um
then get your face bashed getting my
[ __ ] brain smashed to pieces like
it's just
not like i never
and i don't ever regret it and i know
how passionate i was about it when i was
a kid
so if
if i saw that my son or daughter or
whatever had serious talent in a sport
obviously i would try and encourage them
and i will give them
way more support than i think they'd
ever need and i'd i would encourage them
to stick things out to a certain degree
mm-hmm and i would push them when they
need to be pushed so like for example
if they're
so this is a perfect example let's say
they do
um
let's say they do
tennis
and they're in a group
with their friends
and all of a sudden they're excelling so
they get moved into this advanced group
none of their friends are there
and they're like you know [ __ ] this i
don't know if if my if my friends aren't
if my boys aren't there i don't want to
do it
that's when i push them and be like just
try it you'll make new friends just like
try this man come on give it a month if
you still don't want it after a month
and you just want to go back to doing
your friends then do that
um
and then that's the times when i push
them but if they're really literally
there they wake up in the morning and
they're like
it's just a [ __ ] chore like i don't
want to be this because fun it's all
about fun people like especially when it
comes to sport like as soon as you love
you lose the fun out of it
your plateau and you're you're going to
hit a ceiling in terms of how far you're
going to go if you enjoy it
you can become great if you don't enjoy
it
then in my opinion there's always going
to be a limit but i would always
encourage them to
stay in sport because there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of science back behind
like um especially in younger children
that
the more
like the highest level of athletes a lot
of them
were never stuck to one specific sport
so like roger federer for example he did
bear [ __ ]
bear [ __ ] alongside tennis
he did loads of stuff and they said
before he was a professional tennis
before he was when he was a kid he would
play everything he wouldn't just play
tennis uh and they say like a lot of
times if you if your kid excels in one
sport the worst thing you can do is keep
him only playing that sport you should
encourage them to do all sorts of [ __ ]
so that's probably the thing i would
take like for example like i said if
they were if i saw that they were super
talented in boxing then one day they
were just like i just don't want to do
boxing anymore
i wouldn't be like all right cool let's
pack in boxing i'll be like all right
that's that's fine if you're not
enjoying it you're not enjoying it um
let's try something else let's go play
something else and i would always want
to keep them in sport for as long as i
possibly could uh and if they're just
not about sport then it's not about
sport but i think
if they enjoy sport they'll always enjoy
sport
a lot of time they'll say that people
who don't enjoy like people who in older
life don't like going to the gym don't
like transport is because they really
didn't enjoy it as a kid and they
weren't ever encouraged enough to find a
sport or something that they enjoyed so
later on in life they just
they avoided anything that's physical so
i'd always want to keep my hidden sport
and then in the hope that they might
come back around to it and want to do it
again
um
if they were really good but again
boxing's if you want for me because box
is [ __ ] dangerous yeah i know the
only reason i use boxing yeah because of
me yeah i know but yeah boxing's
definitely if you want
but yeah stuff like tennis if i thought
like
man like you
it might take a lot of training but [ __ ]
me you could like especially anything it
sounds silly but money is a big aspect
like for example athletics they could be
amazing at afflecks but there's [ __ ] all
money in netflix so if there's a
comparison in comparison but yeah i
would be like if they were like
amazing athletics and then like this is
[ __ ]
i probably wouldn't push them as hard to
stay with it rather than if it was like
tennis
or football or something that in this
country you can make a serious amount of
money if you're really really good
then i'd probably be like
maybe stick it out for a little bit
longer
um but it's a tough question bros really
no no because with kids man it's just
like
they're your heart and the last thing
you want to do is force them to do
something that they don't want to do
yeah uh and i struggle when i watch like
there's tv shows with the kids
the parents are literally living through
their kid
it's just like
[ __ ] you derma
the [ __ ] are you doing um
and like that's the thing i wish i think
definitely i would have stuck
out at certain things more if i had more
support
but then again a lot of the reasons why
i i didn't stick things out is like i
said in terms of like a friendship thing
reason i quit boxing when i did is
because you and aaron
weren't boxers
and it was like oh john better than that
man obviously they're my boys but
they're all talking about getting up to
do 5 a.m runs and all this stuff and i'm
just like ugh i can't bothered and
tournament here and tournament there and
i was just like [ __ ] this man i just
want to go gym with you man i don't want
to do all this [ __ ] i just want to chill
with my boys i want to go out and like
drink and have fun
um and that is one of the main reasons
why i quit boxing
um
and even before that i was i was kind of
losing love for it because all of her it
was more of a
even i wasn't getting paid it was
actually more turned more into a job
okay even before uni transitioning from
like college to uni times 17 18 going
into like adult divisions and stuff like
that it was becoming more of a job and
it was more about like
i need to make sure i'm fit enough i
need to make sure i'm hitting this
weight because when you're a kid you're
just that way anyway yeah you don't put
or lose weight you just that weight but
when you're getting older i need to lose
weight and then you manage going out and
[ __ ] going gym and getting bigger and
eating all this food trying to get
bigger and i'm just like talking to my
coach and he's like oh if you want to
make this tournament like do you think
you can get down to like 67 kilos and
all this stuff and i'm just like
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] [ __ ] but if
coincidentally you and aaron were like
diehard boxers
and then you were motivated by this
stuff and we would all be doing it
together
living together yeah eating the same
food i would have been gasps yeah yeah
of course of course i've been so excited
bro i'm so excited to fight and all of
us go to these tournaments to see how we
get on i'll be so excited and i would
have stuck it out a lot longer
maybe i would have gone professional
after that but it was in that transition
point where like if my boys ain't doing
it i'm not doing it
um
and like i said i have no regrets that's
going bro no regrets because like here i
am and all these like
for example like you get all these
professional athletes
and they'll be like they could for
example like i'm sure serena vince
williams will probably
say stuff along the lines of like i'm so
glad our dad like never let us quit i'm
so glad our dad was pushed us as much as
he did because look where we are now but
it's like yeah but if you quit tennis
you have never you never know what could
have been what could have been yeah and
when you do realize your potential in a
different field
who's to say that you wouldn't look back
and be like
i'm glad our dad didn't force us to stay
in tennis because look where i am now i
have no regrets about quitting tennis
tennis is cool but
yeah it's like when you don't know what
the other the other side is like yeah
it's easy to be like
i'm happy i'm stuck i'm happy
yeah yeah yeah fair enough mum yeah so
yeah i don't know man i probably
wouldn't push him
it's tough because
if i've seen
dedication in
any form of sport i necessarily wouldn't
push them because
at the end of the day the kid is coming
home to me yeah and i wouldn't want to
be
the one to go out there push them for
them to come home and then resent me oh
100 because all i know for a fact
if i was serena if i was um what's his
name again
um
that's rude of me
richard if i was richard um serena and
venus's pops
and
i did a quote-unquote 78-page plan for
their life
i'm obviously going to always be out
there training and training things i'm
gonna be at everything i'm gonna be at
everything they do but they're always
they're also coming home to me so when
they're coming home to me all we're
gonna be discussing is tennis yeah we're
not gonna be discussing anything else
about their life yeah and
i would i'm pretty sure i'll be able to
see in their faces that
this isn't this is just not what a child
should be doing yeah i know i would
i'll be more inclined to
push them in a sense that okay i can get
you a trainer i can get you this i can
get you that if i can afford i can get
you this this this and this and then you
[ __ ] up and practice with him or her
if you aren't fancying it anymore we can
come home back and we can look at
something else you know i would never
want to be the one that pushes them to
that extent oh bro i'll support them but
i wouldn't want to push them especially
i don't want to be that kind of coach
exactly mike because i imagine like for
example like tennis
these he would have woken up with them
he would have been there on the days
with her dad i don't want to i don't
want to and then he would have been
there
whilst they're slugging it out for eight
hours a day and he would have had to be
the one
like bandaging their blistered hands and
they're crying when they're little girls
and their blistered feet and they're
like
[ __ ] why do we have to do this
he's the one that has to like deal with
all of that like he said like he has to
be out there
he has to be the one at home forcing him
to get out and then he's also the one
that's out there and he has to be the
one to take care of them
when they're bad and bruised and crying
knowing that this morning they were
begging me not to send them out there
and i did it anyway and now look at the
state they're in i
physically couldn't deal with that i'm
tearing it up i physically couldn't deal
with that i physically could not deal
with that yeah literally i'll be like
we're not doing this anymore 100 we're
not doing this anymore [ __ ] this like i
wouldn't be able to put my kid through
that yeah yeah in the hope
that this 78 page plan weren't full of
[ __ ] yeah
how would you even play how did you even
write that [ __ ] noise right he must
have been a [ __ ] tennis genius i'm
intrigued to watch the movie no after
reading that 78 page plan thing because
i'm assuming
like you said because you asked me was
he involved in tennis i'm assuming he is
he must have been he must have been he
can't just be some spectator yeah yeah
so
yeah that's um
that's a tough one to put in your kids
but then again like you said four killer
road they chose the tennis side or
whichever athlete chose their sports
side we don't know what the other side
could have held for them so it's um
it's it's it's it's tough but it's also
here's what it is one life in it you
don't even know what you could do
yeah man one life
it is what is
um
what's your thought on this facebook
thing
the funny thing i was i was reading into
that or trying to read into that on the
way
to the studio today and i heard about i
think maybe two days ago yesterday i
can't remember all i know is that it's
meta and all i know is that
i think it's something to do like
transporting
sight into saturn and that's all i know
i've not read into it okay so
i'm intrigued because i literally got
i've got it open on my phone yeah so
i've got to read it before we even slide
anything oh okay yeah yeah so basically
they want to create obviously the
metaverse
so they're better but you've seen ready
player one haven't you yes it's
basically ready player one okay it's
basically ready player one so uh makes
yes i've read a little bit about it yeah
so he wants it to be like an immersive
virtual reality plus like augmented
reality
basically universe
in which
eventually we'll run our entire economy
yeah one insult family a lot of people
ain't seen it that's did you scare me we
literally had this conversation had this
conversation with
flo yesterday and she ain't seen it i've
seen it like three or four times i've
seen bear time great movies amazing
anyway anyway but yeah
he basically wants to set up a system in
which people
can
do like
normal activities
like meetings like virtual meetings and
[ __ ]
social like going out to
have like a [ __ ] tree like fake
drinks in this universe but also gaming
gaming is going to be the first
transition
but like um instead of having having
separate games you have separate games
but you will always be the same avatar
just like already player one like you'll
just play this game you'll be playing
fortnite and you will be the character
and then you decide i want to play
fortnite anymore i want to go play call
of duty you're going to be the same guy
um so you want to basically
create this
ready player one like universe in which
is basically going to run our entire
economy
in terms of you will be able to earn
money from this
and it's just gonna everything will
slowly
start and obviously you'll be using
cryptocurrencies and all this [ __ ] and
you'll probably have people that are
really good at making [ __ ] so they'll be
on there in their own little marketplace
and you'll go and you'll go to like
it's open marketplace where all these
avatars will be and you go to all these
different shops and people selling nfts
and [ __ ] someone's created this sick
gun that you can use in these three
different games and it's going to cost
you this much and if you want to earn
this [ __ ] ethereum you need to go on
to these like battle royales and you own
currency from playing these games and
eventually
people will be on these [ __ ] games
nine ten eleven hours a day just trying
to make a living
and then at the end of the day you cash
in your [ __ ] coins that you earned
from the games and then work as real
money
and then you'll that's how you'll live
your life oh so it's
it's um kind of replicated into the real
world so the money you earn from the
meta
would i don't know if that's what he
said in the plan but that's just how
these things will go
because you'll be you because it just
makes sense because you'll be
you're going to be using cryptocurrency
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you can use
cryptocurrency now a lot of pieces will
accept crypto now
in real life so if you're earning it
in your gaming world you should be able
to man you should it will go into your
crypto account and you can use that
crypto account for whatever yeah i think
this whole vr thing is
is insane purely because i think
i just think it's going to have such a
negative impact on people's mental
health
oh yeah like i it's as cool as it sorry
to interrupt now it's minor bro as cool
as it sounds don't get me wrong i'm not
gasped by it because i literally think
it's the biggest red flag of all time oh
100 i literally think is the biggest red
flag of all time like it's gonna stop
social i also have a theory once you
finish saying with your piece i have a
theory as well but like um
yeah i think it's the worst thing that
could possibly happen as [ __ ] sick as
i think it would be in terms of the game
in front i don't give a [ __ ] about the
rest of the [ __ ]
i want to do everything as a normal
person for the rest of the [ __ ]
but as far as the game issues that's
cool
don't get me wrong that is very [ __ ]
cool like um as soon as you said ready
player one automatically knew what you
were talking about yeah yeah yeah it is
very [ __ ] cool but
i just think people are gonna
lose sight of reality you know
what i don't think i know for a fact
people are going to lose sight of
reality do already exactly they're going
to
exactly they do already as bad as social
media is for certain people or certain
amounts of people if it
patterns out into a virtual realm of
virtual reality
people are just going to forget where
they really are they're going to
literally live their life for the vr
version of themselves or their their
avatar and not really give a [ __ ] about
anything else they're going to get lost
and they're probably going to die by
playing this thing 100 you know
i think it's going to cause a lot more
casualties than it is
for happiness or like whichever balance
they're trying oh bro it's just going to
be an anxiety field it is hellhole it is
and it's also going to be one of those
ones where
is it
is it a case of
i'm assuming it's something you're going
to have to
pay for of course and it's going to be
something that's not going to be cheap
in my opinion of course not it doesn't
sound cheap
like in in ready player 1 these man
breaking their backs to to actually just
get the whole time new [ __ ] the new [ __ ]
people are breaking their backs together
you know
they're living in [ __ ] boxes just to
play the game too yeah everybody's
living
you know what i mean so i i just don't
think it's um
i think a long story short or what's the
word i'm looking long story short um
long term it's it's gonna have such a
negative negative effect on the world
yeah definitely um
i think it's a terrible thing i think
it's so cool but i also think it's a
terrible thing
many cool factors about of course sorry
it's got you off again there are many
cool factors about it but i just think
long term it's just not
it's not viable
it's dead but um i can see like
it's almost like you can just it's the
next logical step i was literally just
about to say that it's the next thing
yeah because the world doesn't go
backwards because we can't go back as
well until everything implodes we can't
go back yeah and basically what my
theory is is i actually think this is
the next evolutionary step in terms of
like
um
gender interpretations
explain so obviously we live in a world
now
i think i know what you're trying to say
but we're like the the i don't even know
the
i struggle for the words for it but
basically just like
the trans
community community yeah is such a
prominent
discussion at the minute
and then people like identifying
themselves as trans
in any way shape or form i've got a
question to ask you remind me after the
call about drugs is all um it's so
prominent right now and there's so much
discussion about gender and some people
are like gender fluid some people like
this something like that there's
[ __ ] 148 000 different genders or
whatever
and then people are always discussing
are you a real woman are you a real man
is this the is this class as this what
toilet should they use
like are you transphobic if you want to
sleep with like a a trans um woman etc
etc etc and um
in the meta verse
all of those questions go away go away
you are who you decide to be and then
people will just stop meeting in real
life and if i'm [ __ ] a ting
in the metaverse and she's banging and
she's got nine tits
and we have a great time yeah
it could be a breath
on the other side of that headset it
could be a massive disgraceful breath
but we don't ask any questions here in
matter we just do what we're here to do
i see what my eyes see yeah and my tool
feels on my toes
and that's just how we play yeah and i
don't ask any questions they don't ask
me any questions we don't ever use our
real names we don't ever show our real
faces and then we just do our thing and
that
to me is the next evolutionary step in
terms of all of the gender discussions
put to bed yeah
put to bed yeah whatever identity and
not even just gender but just identity
in general yeah yeah yeah you throw
yourself in the metaverse you could be
whoever you want to be and there's no
point in people asking questions there's
no point people saying yeah but you're a
guy and you're a [ __ ] avatar girl
then no one knows who you are yeah just
[ __ ] go out and have fun
that's
that's what scares me in terms of it
being the next evolutionary step
logically because it's like we're in
this such a weird confusing time at the
minute when no one knows what to say no
one knows who they are
everyone wants to be someone else
[ __ ]
filters are scary good yeah filters are
scary no yeah it looks like she should
yeah filters are terrifyingly good
like makeup tutorials are terrifyingly
good
the next step that just
stops all of this
confusion is zuckerberg's metaverse will
you be who you want to be in there is
literally
this whole thing where everyone's like
where does this end like where does it
send everyone's getting counsel because
they're saying the wrong [ __ ] everyone's
saying this like the trans community
[ __ ] hates everyone like
lgbtq
[ __ ]
abc community hates everyone for this
like everyone's confused everyone's
scared
and then mark zuckerberg comes out on a
[ __ ] wednesday afternoon says by the
way guys
we're creating this thing and you can go
in there you can be who you want and you
can basically live your whole life on
there and everyone's like ah
well that problem solved problem solved
yeah like we don't have to have
discussion anymore it's done and then
you're like
in terms of what you said like
you can never go back yeah
and then
females will never have to use a filter
again you've got one look and you can
change your look whenever you want yeah
and then
guys won't have to go gym anymore i
still will but
um
guys won't have to go gym anymore like
you can do what you want you can look
how you want you add how you want you
have whatever job you want
and it's just like
[ __ ]
it has to it
as much as it's scary as it is there's
no way it won't happen
because it
resolves
so many is the next step sociological
issues yeah it is the next step
it's crazy yeah it sucks there has to be
a huge form of
an
anonymity i think can't get the word out
yeah yeah yeah but the question i was
going to ask you not the rel this is
related to what we're talking about i've
got another question but the this
question related to this um transgender
transgender topic i was at work the
other day
and
there was a i'm assuming i'm assuming a
transgender mentor woman
and she
it was me and two other colleagues on
the receptionist and my colleagues were
they're women they're women so i was
asking them
how would you feel
this was just genuine a genuine general
question i didn't ask them this question
because i wanted to prompt an answer i
was just you know curious because she
went into the guys toilets
and not the girls toilets and we could
see the toilets from where we stood so i
was asked i asked them as ladies if you
were in the toilets and you saw a
transgender mantle woman go into the
ladies toilets how would you feel they
both said they'd be calm you'd feel safe
blah blah blah yada yada i was like okay
if the roles were reversed
and you were um
and a transgender guy
um
to a woman
went into men
women's toilets how would you feel
and they said
they'd be a bit standoffish
and i said why he said because as as
women they
that it's a double standard kind of
thing they said they wouldn't know how
to feel
but because so the one that's that
office this is someone who is
biologically a woman so the biology but
yeah i can't get my words out today
so biological
man
trans
gender woman transgender woman now using
the women's toilets now using the
women's toys they're standoffish no no
they said they would be okay with it
that's what i thought you said yeah they
said they'd be okay with it and i said
what if a biological woman who's now a
transgender man mm-hmm went to the
women's toilet
however standoffish they said they'll be
a standoffish and i said
but if they identified that what what's
the problem because they said with the
woman with transgender mental woman they
said if they identify as that then why
is that a problem then i get obviously
flipped
did a reverse uno on them and they said
i get what you're saying but also it is
what they decide to do but i'd be a bit
standoffish and i was like why because
um they said something along the lines
of not necessarily feel threatened or
whatever but because of the fact that
stature-wise
they can see that this person is much
more bigger than them and this than the
other and we were talking about
um unisex toilets and things
like how would you
feel if um
how would you feel if
you were in in a in a venue that just
had unisex toilets because they were
talking about a spot in money that has
unisex toilets
and they said
ah they'd want they wouldn't want a
transgender whichever whichever side
you're going to from man to woman or
woman to man
to
be in the same place as a
as a regular person in the unisex
toilets and i was like why and they said
because they just they don't know
whether they'll feel safe or not and i
was like okay but then you've kind of
got double standards here do you not
think
but he also raised the then we got on to
another completely another random point
about
if
a
if a man has a
little girl like a daughter
and he's either a single parent or he's
only out with a daughter for the day
and the daughter wants to go toilet what
toilet does she go into
and they both said
to the men's toilet i was like why
though
if there's a little girl that
wants to go to the toilet surely she
should be able to go to the the man
should be
escort her escort her into the toilet
and the women in the toilet should
understand that big man this is my
little girl what else can i do yeah yeah
um and you're like
that's a bit sticky but i was like it's
the same thing as a
a man trans trans um trans woman going
into the women's toilet you said you'd
be okay with that
so what's the difference here
you know yeah yeah it was it was a weird
conversation because it it came it came
out because obviously i saw
i'm assuming a transgender mental woman
dining in a restaurant and then i saw
them going to the men's wallets so we
had this open discussion yeah and then
it got into the kids one i think what's
what's the difference here
it was it was it was interesting for
about five minutes and then we just
moved on and of course of course yeah
there's only so far you can go yeah
yeah in those conversations yeah that's
interesting
um
i personally i mean obviously i'm i have
the privilege of not being a woman and
not have to worry about whether i feel
safe or not yeah so i personally don't
give a [ __ ] who uses what toilet
um
and that's the thing as well was like it
would be nice
if i could
if i was with like
my daughter or whatever it would be nice
if i could take her into the
the woman's toilets
obviously i know that's a no-go
but bringing a little girl into a men's
toilet
i think
maybe
it would have been nice yeah i feel like
maybe if
your everyday woman could actually see a
man's toilets they might feel not so
against
because like as unsafe as you feel
me coming into your toilet with like my
daughter you have no idea how unsafe
this little girlfriend is gonna man's
toilet is the scariest i'm a grown-ass
man and i didn't even like going in the
man's store the scariest place you
couldn't think of yeah um
so yeah maybe if women spent more time
in a men's toilet they wouldn't feel so
bad about a guy coming in with his
daughter in a women's toilet because
[ __ ] me muzzle is no good place this is
not man it's weird it is weird but like
yeah i don't personally don't give a
[ __ ] and like
again realistically
like uh there's certain restaurants and
stuff like zzz's
pretty sure aziz just have individual
cubicles okay
toilet they just have toilet mm-hmm and
they might actually have split it
this is a man one this woman when it's a
man once a woman it really doesn't [ __ ]
him out they've got that in alchemist as
well yeah yeah so there's just massive
like individual cubicles individual
pupils there's no toilet area yeah yeah
you just it's a hallway yeah there's a
sink in there there's a toilet in there
yeah like
i think it should just be just [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] man
who gives a [ __ ] and also an interesting
one is also uh
20 stories
yes that has separate sections but the
washing area is like all wonderful yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um so yeah it's
it's [ __ ] it's a heartless weird
conversation and then when you get down
to it like you said you spoke about five
minutes and then you just said [ __ ]
it's one of them was just like i don't i
don't want to have this conversation
it's just such a stupid conversation but
everyone has their opinion on the
conversation of course of course it's
stupid but yeah uh the whole
that's what i'm saying the metaverse
gonna take off everything bro because
the whole thing is just
so confusing no one knows what to say no
one wants to do
some people think everyone deserves this
and if some people think everyone
deserves that and then people get like
chastised for saying
how they truly feel and then people
pretend like they don't understand how
that person can feel that way because
they don't want to get canceled
themselves and it's just like it's so
long bro it's turning into one big black
mirror episode
yeah wow yeah it's turned into one big
black mirror episode bro so long
um right i'm gonna shift the question
completely left okay and we have like a
small fan request okay cool
right
so man said
hello big time fan long time listener to
the pod uh can you do something
on body count
so a few of my friends needed to know
how to address it
especially the typical answer that all
films give of three as a baseline on
their body read this when it came in
so i said we'll have a chat about it
um
i'll let you go first
so is that what he said so all he said
he just wants to know what won for um
body count but he was female specific
right female specifically yeah yeah yeah
on a female account um
bro in this day and age i don't ask i
don't think i've ever asked a girl what
their body count is because
one i don't care but if i ask and they
give me an answer then i think i will
start to care because
it's just something that you now know
it's information that information you
weren't privy to before
you don't necessarily start to speculate
about
so if a girl let's say outside our mind
exactly if there's a girl i'm seeing and
she's told me uh her bodyguard's 20 for
example
i start to think i start to calculate
things in my head for no reason how old
is she when does she lose her virginity
yeah you know all these stupid things
are irrelevant yeah you know yeah i
don't care what your body count is yeah
if you love sex big man you love sex i
love sex yeah so what yeah also i
personally don't
really care what a woman's body count is
we've said it in um
in um
some of the questions and answers we do
on them on instagram like people talk
about body count who said ladies if you
love sex do your thing we i don't care
i'm pretty sure you feel the same way i
just don't care i've got one sentence
for my man
thank you so much for the message bro
and for like for you and your friends
the best way in my opinion to think
about it is is if you care about a
woman's body count
you're a [ __ ] bro
you're a [ __ ]
i just don't you're a [ __ ] who cares
you're an absolute
[ __ ] you must be young i'm assuming you
don't know
no it'll look young
even if yes i think it's such a young
question to ask but even if you are
young bro if you're even if you're 14 if
you're ever contemplating asking a girl
what a body count is you are a [ __ ]
just don't do it man bro have a look at
yourself in the mirror and say do i want
to be a [ __ ] for the rest of my life
yes or no if the answer is yes go ahead
and ask her and he answers no
just move on with your life it literally
it has no relevance it has no relevance
if you think a girl's pinging you on a
banger what's her telling you a
bodyguard going to change yeah what's
that going to change and then he was
talking about in terms of uh
three is the general answer that they
give first of all i don't know what the
general answer is because i've never
asked and i don't want to know and it's
like oh how do we navigate through like
all they want to say is three like how
do we get to the truth what the [ __ ] is
this leave them out if you get to the
truth what have you gained what benefit
is you what have you guys there's no
good answer there is no we've definitely
had this conversation before there's
literally no good answer if she tells
you one for starters you're ever going
to think she's lying well she is lying
yeah true
or who's this one fan yeah
why am i the second yeah why am i the
second to even do i even want to be
number two that's a lot of pressure
there's a lot of pressure she says none
definitely i don't want to know exactly
um if she says 20 for example like yeah
like you said i'm starting to think [ __ ]
deep down do i even give a [ __ ] if it's
100 no but now that i've asked i have to
then process the answer in my head yeah
you have to deal with that yeah
every time you bank her you know you're
number 101. yeah yeah every time you
banger and this is like i didn't care
but now i know i kind of have to care
and it's like um it's like it's random
but like it's
it's like if i'm at a dinner table and i
order steak
and then some [ __ ] whoever i'm with
is like
is this steak locally sourced
do i give a [ __ ] if it's locally sourced
rain no i don't give a [ __ ]
but if they answer say nah it's not
locally sourced oh my god i'm thinking
hmm what does that mean
where did it come from then i don't care
but because i've got that answer my
brain's doing [ __ ] that i have no
control over and then i'm thinking now i
want to ask him how unlocally is this
wrong where is it from fab is it from
great britain is it from germany is it
even a cow
yeah
is it even actually cow like i've got
all these questions that i never gave a
[ __ ] about before but now i've got an
answer my brain has to do something with
the information and now i'm curious and
now i'm vex because i want to know
i never would i never wanted to know
before
ah yeah man yeah we don't care if the
puss is locally sourced my g
enjoy the time that you're in there
exactly man enjoy the medium rare white
last five yeah just know that if she's
paying her dms blow up and it's up to
her what she's done with it exactly bro
it's not your concern it's not your
concern bro just play your role man who
if you ask her body count you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] play your role my g you
said it well play your role ma'am play
your role there's no point in asking
said questions boy
it doesn't it amounts to nothing it
amounts to
less than nothing
it's just
you've just given her the biggest ick of
all time yeah oh fact you've given her
the biggest because you're a little boy
yeah oh you're a little boy
you're a little boy you're on her chest
and you're looking at me out baby how
many people have you slept with
your little boy
your hair there's stroke in your hair
she just comfortably ended your waves
you felt comfortable enough to say babe
like i know it's a bit of a personal
question but how many people have you
set with you're just looking up you look
up like that
you little boy
you're a little boy oh [ __ ] you know
because you're not gonna believe any
answer she gives you exactly what you
just said like oh all girls say three so
what do you want big man if she says
three what if it's three what if it
actually is three
big man just leave it it's an irrelevant
topic man that care about body count are
such [ __ ] it's ridiculous james said
it best bro sorry it's outrageously i
was even watching you know when they do
these youtube dating shows and stuff
yeah and i always see the clips on tik
tok and stuff like that and i'm just
scrolling through yeah there's one i
don't know what the show is but it's one
mixed race yeah she's like kinda peng
and she goes through these guys yeah and
they have like it's like a date but they
have like in-depth discussions and it's
always like what kind of girl are you
into what kind of guy you're into all
this stuff and then there's always one
that pops up and it's always about body
count and one guy's going off like if my
goals [ __ ] with
x amount of guys double digits i'm not
dealing with double digits all this
stuff and i just hear and i think oh
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] it's a problem it's it's an
irrelevant question man no one should be
asking that kind of question no bro if a
girl asks me that question i'll walk out
you don't need to don't ask me
silly billy questions
ask me silly billy questions
like what's the point ask me that
question
what is the point because whichever
whichever number i give
it's affected us now 100 it's affected
us now 100
yeah yeah just know bro we're doing all
these eggs
bro asking our body count trust me
that's red [ __ ] just like
yeah dried up from dry it up absorbed
all the moisture in the air just about
back into our bloodstream
yeah
you just dried up the naan quicker than
you could ever think of
dehumidified the thing
it's dead
it's dead fam oh
i can't even imagine being a girl
attracted to a guy and him have asked me
how many guys have i slept with
it's just
yeah yeah let's move on
[Laughter]
i think let's we've spoken about already
you said you had a question or a trash
news or something i've got both yeah go
for it
well this is a question
statement
and when i say this i want you to think
about it in
as an i want you to think about it as an
adult like with it through an adult's
perspective as opposed to what it really
is
i don't understand but you understand
once i say it all right go ahead go go
go go go go this is more of a statement
i want you to
it's coming from an adult's perspective
right
don't you think
the game simon says
is [ __ ] creepy
[Laughter]
oh no
i actually is
oh wow it's very like sub dom fam i was
thinking about it the other day i don't
know why it came to my head but i was
just thinking about it the other day and
my mind started speaking in here's what
i thought
so
for those that don't know the premise of
the game simon says i'm pretty sure most
of you do in the world but for those
that don't it's a game you probably pray
like primary school whatever um it's an
adult
with a bunch of kids
um and they say simon says jump and then
the kids jump simon says laugh the kids
laugh and if i as the adult spin around
and kids spin around they're out the
game because i didn't say simon says we
got it good great gang cool
so
obviously a little three four five year
old didn't create the game simon says
yeah there wasn't like a little group of
year fives or five-year-olds or
four-year-olds in the playground
thinking what's the next game we can
play because i'm bored i'm [ __ ] bored
and they are simon over there yeah yeah
yeah and then simon says i don't know
and then everyone else says oh i don't
know taking a piss out of him and they
go like oh gang that's the new game
simon says that didn't happen simon
rocked up so obviously
in my head how the game panned out back
a day
back a day when [ __ ] was illegal
but you could get away with it
there was a donny down the road called
simon
and he had kids in his basement
i'll let you think of that what you will
he just had kids in his basement
hey
jesus that was a bit further than i
thought
my idea was i don't know how else it
would have panned out my idea was just
like
simon was just a creepy don
that lived down the road probably had a
garage completely separate to his yard
around the back
and he just had like
he just like i don't know man he had
weird [ __ ] in his garage that kids
thought was cool and then he'd get all
these kids together and then they'd be
like he'd be like oh
why don't you guys like tickle each
other and then tickle each other
and then he'd like oh
let's just get our let's just get our
shirts off a couple mine were like
nah big man that's not happening like
were you on the back and he's like all
right say let's say let's say let's say
this
say let's say that's too far too far too
far let's play a little game all right
cool yeah what's the game what's the
game oh it's a really hard game so if i
say
take your tops off
don't do it but if i say simon says take
your tops off you have to do it whatever
i say simon says you have to do it and
be like alright cool
bet that sounds easy cool
yeah yeah touch your nose no oh you're
out
simon says touch your nose yeah cool
cool simon says brush your hair yeah
someone says touch floor
take a t-shirt off
well played well played
sam says getting in these
bam it spiraled from there
simon was rallying the troops
that's all i'm saying bro the game
sounds i don't like that you thought of
that bro you actually beat it
who's simon who is simon who's simon
peter's name as well who is simon i
can't think of a pwa name peter we are
i can't think of a peter weir name
why do you just say more peter phillips
nah bro that's too graphic a peter weir
named more peter we are
yeah man bro who's simon who is simon
that's a real question who's simon yeah
bro fair play i'm not about that
i'm not a badass it makes you thinking
it does make you think there's a bear
[ __ ] like that that makes you think
if i can because universally everyone
just cracks on with the game yeah bro
but how did it pan out
[ __ ] like that there's like [ __ ] um
what's it called it's called um
oh like the like the story of the pied
piper
yeah
um that's me i don't want to talk about
that anymore i'll be serious that's
actually stressing me out right it's
crazy in it it's very crazy it's crazy
bro i i didn't when i thought i was like
yo
that's random it is very random so
anyway guys
let's try not to think too much about
where children's games come from
if we've learned anything from squid
game
is that
when you're a child we leave the child
games yeah we put them things to bed
yeah yeah and it's just it's just that
it's just that let's not think too
deeply about it because
we all need sleep we all need rest
and we don't need sleepless nights
uh but anyway guys we're gonna wrap it
up there yeah mom um
meet us over on thursday for some more
juicy juice of course we've got some fun
topics to get through yeah man uh we
love you guys and um
stay easy going love love peace
[Music]